there was actually a very very big
mistake in the movie The Secret the
story that was told was that all you
have to do is think believe in your
heart and you'll achieve it's not true
there's a lot of people who think
wonderful great thoughts they believe
that I deserve this and I can have this
but they don't do one thing they don't
take consistent action every day in the
secret they didn't talk about you have
to do the right things in the right
order at the right time and they let a
lot of people to believe that all you
have to do is think about it I've never
met a monk in a monastery who's been
praying to make money and through the
ceiling a safe Falls with a million
dollars I've never met that yet and but
I have met a lot of people who think and
believe and then they learn what they
need to learn they upgrade their
knowledge and their skills they overcome
their fears they overcome their doubts
and they take action anyway and then
little by little things start to happen
for them they achieve the results and we
call that the law of Goya Law of
Attraction and law of Goya together
that's what works consistent action is
the cure-all whatever problem you have
whatever issue you're facing whatever
big life you want to create for yourself
the way to get there is not some giant
short burst of effort it's the daily
consistent grinding action that will
help you accomplish your goals people
look at my channel and
a lot of new people have joined over the
past number of years hey welcome board
great to have you welcome to believe
Nation it's a positive happy place it's
great to have you here it's an honor to
be a part of your daily routine
if you go and look at my my channel my
main channel in the history it took so
many years guys so many years of just
making content and not seeing any
results
I took I forget what the number is it
took five years to get to 9 000
something subscribers and another five
years to get almost two million
subscribers now we're sitting over three
million subscribers Etc
I haven't missed
an upload every single day
for I don't know
eight years
something crazy like that
every day
I've made videos through
travel I've made videos through elect
electricity electricity outages I made
videos through breaking my neck I made
videos through my tour I made videos
through vacation I made videos I made
videos I made videos I made videos I
made videos I made videos and you can
plan you can prepare you can get ahead
you can you can batch them
but I don't think your goals count until
they're hard
it's when it gets hard when when you get
tested that's when you have to show
yourself What You're Made Of
even little things like
I remember filming at my dance studio in
Toronto
and I had my camera guy and my assistant
and we're filming and the electricity
goes out
and then there's a fire alarm
they go I guess we can't film like the
first thing that that my camera guy says
is okay well I guess we can't film I
can't film but it's like electricity
outage and then
fire alarm
fire alarm
you can't film with that it's like I'm
I'm filming today
so I took my phone it was freezing
outside I took my phone went outside and
just started filming
because videos have to go up
they have to go up
I've I've made videos with my broken
neck
I broke my neck in two spots had a
concussion
and I
next week I'm making videos
they weren't as long they weren't as
good
I'm wearing a neck brace if you look at
the old videos I'm wearing this giant
neck brace I got this giant scab here on
my forehead because I smashed my head
against the wall
when I fainted and that's how it led to
the concussion broken neck I'm still
making videos
not making videos is not an option
and so if you look at someone like me
who
is introverted is shy who doesn't like
the camera who always thought that
people who were famous had a big ego who
I still don't like being on stage I
still get nervous every single time
but I still have a message
and I still want to serve how does
somebody like that
have this kind of Channel well because
of every single day making videos you've
done over 10 000 videos I've done over
10 000 videos that's crazy
not all of them are public
but even just on the main Channel let
alone this channel on the top 10 channel
the other channel 10 000 Plus videos
over 12 years
why
how
it's just a consistent action
I think most people lose because
we overestimate what we can do
in a really
short period of time and underestimate
what we can do in a long period of time
you think by putting in three weeks of
hard work you're gonna crush it
but really if you just stayed on it like
guys you've had ideas you have enough
you've you have had an idea that you'd
love that you gave up on too soon that
if you just kept doing it this is an
idea that you had maybe three years ago
that if you just found the way to keep
doing it even part-time even on the side
even on the weekends if you just kept at
it you'd be in a different place right
now
something would have happened something
would have paid off
but we're too frustrated to get
something to happen right now and I get
it I'm there too I'm I'm impatient I
want immediate results I want things to
happen I'm putting my best I want this
video right now to be the best one I've
ever done and I put my effort to try to
make that happen and I fully recognize
at the same time that
it's a long game
that you have to keep going
and that it's your purpose you can't
give up on it
most people just quit too soon
you just quit too soon
and that's you quitting on your dream
and it was your dream and you want it to
happen it's a daily consistent Act
action to make it happen
so how do you do it let me give you some
tactics so that you can not just get
motivated from a message but actually
apply it to your life number one you
have to create a calendar
these videos happen because they're in
my calendar
I'm filming this on a Tuesday Tuesday is
my YouTube day I always film on Tuesday
I block it off in my calendar
I just came back from vacation and on
the Tuesday of my week I was still
making videos people say well still work
on vacation first off it's not work like
I like this this is fun for me this
isn't this isn't oh I have to go make
videos if that was my mindset I would
I'd be out I wouldn't do it anymore
but also if you're on vacation you're
making videos or you're doing a little
bit of work
to spend three hours
of a 24-hour day
doing something
is totally achievable somebody uh one of
the people that I invested into
yesterday's like how do I take a
vacation on my business
like how do I my wife wants to know how
do I go on vacation and run this
business like you can still you can
either plan ahead and get ahead with all
your clients or you can still do some
work
do you not have personal time are you
going to be around your wife 24 hours a
day does your wife not want to go to the
spa or spend some time on the beach it's
not about the three hours that you spend
working it's about
the other hours at 21 hours you get to
sleep but whatever all the other hours
that you have the day it's about
intentional time most of most people's
life is not intentional most of your
vacation time is not intentional either
if you were to spend 21 hours a day with
your wife
intentionally creating an amazing
relationship
then the three hours a day you're going
to spend working
as easy as nothing
of course you could take time off
but you have to put in your calendar
you have to create a calendar that makes
sense for you
schedule in when you're actually going
to make your dreams happen because
otherwise it's a dream I could say I
want to make YouTube videos but if it
was never my calendar guess what it
would never happen and this applies for
life too every uh every afternoon
at 2 30 I spend time with Nina with my
wife
we spend time in the morning I take an
intentional break at 2 30 we go to the
park we take we take the dogs with us
we we stay inside and just be together
if it's raining like we'll spend time
every day every weekday at 2 30 because
I want I wanted to spend more time with
Nina during the week weekends we're
basically all in on on the relationship
but the weekdays can be crazy you know
so we spend time in the morning we spend
time in the evening and I wanted to
spend
2 30. it's 25 minutes together but
intentional 25 minutes that intentional
25 minutes is worth more than three
hours of just sitting in front of a TV
that's not time together
you have a lot more time than you think
just not being intentional that's the
problem if you feel like you got to the
end of the week and you were so busy but
you got nothing done
and everything's falling apart you're
just not intentional with your time
so you schedule it in whatever you want
in a life whatever your dream life looks
like whatever your goals Ambitions
motivations are put in your calendar
two
be the person who follows through on
their calendar
stop letting yourself off the hook
for not following through on your
calendar
I'm a little tired today because we just
came back from our trip I'm a little jet
lagged from coming out from the West
I'm still making videos I'm still videos
have to be made they're going up like
when do you let yourself break
if it's in the calendar it has to happen
videos have to happen today I don't care
if I'm lying in bed I don't care I don't
care if I'm in the hospital I've made
videos from the hospital I don't care
where videos have to come up I don't
care if they're the best videos the best
with what I can make right now
if I'm tired they might be lower than my
standard
but it's the best of what I can make
right now if I'm in the hospital it's
definitely lower than what I can make
out of the hospital but I'm going to
make the best of what I can make right
now
be the person who follows through on the
things that you say you're gonna do
because the next time you put something
in your calendar the next time we see
you're gonna get that goal or
do this project you're going to the next
day wake up I'm not I can't do that I'm
not doing that
you're starting to build the identity
either way of the person who follows
through or the person who doesn't follow
through
and every time you say yes to yourself
every time you do it when it's difficult
you start to build up that identity a
little bit more I follow through I
follow through I follow through so then
the next time you put something in your
calendar the next time come up with a
goal you start to believe that it's
actually possible for you to do it
because you're building that identity of
you being the person who actually
follows through
and every time you let yourself off the
hook every time you give yourself a
break every time you say it's okay I'm
not going to do it today every time you
say that
you eat away at that other identity and
start to build a new one
the new identity of the person who
doesn't follow through
you start to believe yourself a little
bit less
the next goal you write down is a little
less credible you don't think you can do
it you're going to realize the next day
that you're not going to follow through
and says it's very
slippery slope to fall down
so step one is you build a calendar step
two is you become the person who sticks
to your calendar
who follows through on the things that
you say you're going to do that's why
it's important to create a realistic
calendar don't tell me don't tell
yourself you're going to make 100 videos
a day every day
you're going to make a thousand phone
calls a day every day
you're not you're going to write 100
love letters to your wife every day
you're not you're not it's not going to
happen make it a realistic plan for
something you can actually stick to
because again if you just stick to it
guys you will hit your goals
if you stop quitting on yourself if you
stop letting yourself off the hook that
idea you had three years ago should have
already come to Creation because you
just stuck with it just stick with it
step number three so create a calendar
one stick to your calendar number two
three
the environment around you really
matters
videos like this really matters why
create the inspressor to be with you
every morning to give you the Boost to
bring new people like John astraff and
Oprah and Elon Musk and these people who
lift you up who inspire you hopefully
that's the intention every time
join a group like movement makers be a
part of a community be around other
entrepreneurs who are doing things we're
chasing their dreams we're trying to
make their thing happen when you're when
you create that environment and you
start to shift it
it inspires you to want to play bigger
it inspires you to want to stay
consistent when you are feeling at your
lowest low when you're about to quit on
the thing that you said that you want to
do that's in your calendar you see it
you see it today I'm supposed to do that
like I don't want to do that what brings
you out of it
it's the habits it's the environment
it's the routine
watch another video
join our group like movement makers
get a mentor coach
have an accountability buddy
you have to be around the people who
constantly fill your cup who give you
light who lift you up who make you
believe and help you feel like it's
possible when you do those three things
your life will change
create a calendar
that mapped your actions to your
ambitions
be the person who follows through on
their calendar
and then be around the people videos
resources environment
that encourages you that lifts you up
and makes you feel like it's possible
also to make
after watching this video
has been a special
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all of the
Lessons Learned in this video as well as
pull out our three favorite learnings
and quotes that will inspire you to
actually do something the worksheet will
also give you space to write down what
your key takeaways are and your specific
plan of action to make sure you're
getting results if you want the
worksheet design specifically for this
video absolutely for free there's a link
in the description below go click on it
and start building the momentum in your
life and your business I'll see you
there
if you can self-observe
then you can turn it outwards but it all
starts with being
self-observing awareness of when I'm
uncomfortable how do I respond when I'm
doubtful how do I feel when I've got
negative self-talk going on what's going
on when I'm procrastinating what am I
fearful of what am I most
procrastination by the way is done
because of low self-esteem
if you knew how to get something done
you could do it highly effectively and
on time and you were loving it you
didn't do it but most people
procrastinate because they feel doubtful
they don't have all the information
they're procrastinating because they're
worried that if they don't do it
perfectly somebody's going to judge them
cognitive priming right so what's
cognitive time so think about this when
um a baby is learning how to eat okay
what does you know Mommy or Daddy do
mommy or daddy you know takes the spoon
and you know she puts it in the jar she
pretends to eat it herself and then she
puts it into the baby's mouth open the
mouth and she does that to cue the
baby's brain of what to do so she
pretends she's doing it herself she gets
the baby to do it and through this
repetition a baby will learn spoon in
the hand in the jar spoon has food on it
mommy's opening her mouth she's bringing
it to me open my my mouth I put the food
in my mouth oh this yummy thing feels so
good um
eat this food and so if you think about
what's actually happening we're getting
the motor cortex of her brain going
we're getting her taste buds going you
know at a certain point we'll put the
spoon in her mouth and put her hand in
the jar so that she could do it for
herself so we're priming her through
Visual cues through auditory cues
through taste cues right through all of
the different senses we're priming her
brain and then we're reinforcing it day
after day after day after day to create
the neural network the connections in
the brain that if I want that yummy food
in my mouth I have to learn how to take
the spoon in my hand put it in the jar
get it all over the place initially
until I could do it without spilling it
all over the place well that takes you
know we and months and years to tie your
shoes to learn how to eat to learn how
to brush your teeth all these things
that are automatic now yes all the
things that are automatic now so before
something's automatic it's not yeah and
it can feel really uncomfortable so so
let's take
um
a disempowering belief that you have I'm
not good enough I'm not smart enough I'm
too young I'm too old I'm female I'm
whatever it is you have a disempowering
belief it's a nothing more than a
pattern in the brain so somehow a
pattern that wasn't there before got
there
right who told you that your parents
your teachers your brother your sister
your best friend said ah you'll never
remember like who did that it's really
irrelevant but if the pattern is there
and it's a dominant pattern because
you've believed it for 20 30 40 years
whatever the case might be and it's been
reinforced
what does brain science say about how
the F do I get rid of it and it says
well you'll never get rid of it but you
can deactivate it okay how do I
deactivate it right how do I deactivate
it so every time I catch myself saying
I'm not good enough or fill in the blank
feel take any limiting belief and
anytime you catch yourself saying it or
feeling it
what if you said to yourself
stop
in the past I used to believe that and
now I believe I'm more than good enough
in the past I used to feel like I'm too
young but now I can use my age as a
benefit to achieve that goal
any limiting belief we can do one of a
couple things we can say in the past I
used to
and so what we're doing is we're not
saying no stop that we're not
reinforcing a limiting belief by trying
to fight it we acknowledge it's just the
pattern embracing it and just say in the
past I used to believe that and now
here's what I'm choosing to believe so
now what I'm doing is I'm taking an
existing neural pattern and I'm changing
the pattern I'm taking away its
energetic Force by adding new words that
I'm choosing Now versus the ones that
were given to me or the ones that I felt
when I was too young to actually change
it on my own then so now I'm paying
attention to my self-talk I'm paying
attention I'm paying attention to the
inner critic a lot of times when we are
focusing on what we've lost
or what we're losing we're not focusing
on what we've gained
a lot of times we're focusing okay on
what's possible as a result of this we
we tend to Mono Focus right on either
good or bad I like it I don't like it it
tastes good it doesn't it's hurting me
it's not but what if you could learn how
to observe both
what if you could observe the law of
polarity in its entirety that says you
cannot have an electron without a proton
and in without an out and up without a
noun you cannot have that on this planet
in this universe
so is it possible that with just a
little bit of training whether it's
mindfulness or meditation or awareness
you can be sad
you can grieve
and be joyful and happy at the same time
see it's when we are afraid that we're
losing something that we've got that
Frankenstein brain of our saying what if
what if what if what if oh my God oh my
God oh my God oh my God oh my God when
we are in that state we can't be focused
on what are we going to do about it now
in a grieving State like with my mother
um the only thing I want to do about is
make sure that we respect and honor her
life and my brothers and sisters and my
dad Etc so I need to focus on that and
when we're talking about you know a
business going under a relationship you
know that's unraveling right now
if you're focusing on all of the
disempowering emotions and circumstances
you cannot be focusing on the solution
to that possible problem
so you have to learn how to manage the
emotions and for those who don't know
what that's like I want you to imagine I
just gotta really imagine
oh a Hollywood actor or actress learns
that they are not their emotions they
have emotions
now everybody's going to grieve
differently
but I want people to understand that you
don't have to be disempowered in grief
you could be empowered in grief and
everybody's going to do it differently
and some people are going to go inside
some will go outside but we have the
ability to frame things in ways that
Empower us and gives us the best chance
to move forward instead of being a
victim of it
and all I'm saying is consider consider
that you have way more power than you
are displaying in your emotional
Management in your focus in your
awareness and in your behavior and you
can feel the entire spectrum of emotions
totally cool with that but are you being
constructive versus destructive in your
behaviors do we have to develop trust
and Rapport first if I don't trust you
and I don't have any rapport with you
I will not pay attention to your brand
so hey Philip
right so I have to come up with a way to
build trust and Rapport first before I
do anything else so
how can I how can you build trust and
rapport with people
who don't know you or like you or trust
you yet so how can you build trust and
Rapport first
all right how do you build trust and
Rapport first
and the answer is
come on I'm reading all your comments
give away some of your expertise give
away some of your knowledge give away
some of your best stuff
thank you Victor John give away your
your techniques your tools your advice
and so here's my question for you how
can you and
Ace Mantra or as Mantra how can you
give away stuff to people who need what
you have so think about your brand
and ask yourself
the people who may want to buy my
products or my services my knowledge my
skills
what is it that I could give the people
that
needs some help right now
so can you give them
tools tips techniques can you do q a
sessions to answer their questions can
you give them infographics can you give
them videos can you give them something
written can you give them something to
make them feel like they like you trust
you and they want maybe want to do
business with you so you have to make
let me just make sure I use the right
word you have to create the environment
of trust and Rapport I I do free
sessions every Tuesday here
taking what I've learned over 40 years
of building companies over 40 years of
successes and failures over 40 years of
investing millions of dollars whether
it's in marketing
uh hundreds of millions of dollars you
know in marketing and sales over 40
years
um I give away a lot of free stuff
whether it's on my YouTube channel on
LinkedIn on Instagram
um on Facebook wherever it is I give
away a lot of free stuff I was really
fortunate when I was 19 years old I met
a wonderful gentleman who was very
successful with his family it was very
successful giving to Charities he was
very healthy he was very uh gentle and
kind and when he started to share with
me to teach me that my entire reality
was based on what I believed was real
and what I believed was true about
myself about what's possible
and that I could change that
is when my life started to change and he
said if you start to change the way you
think
and you start to learn every day for one
hour to upgrade your knowledge and your
skills and then you take action every
day on the things that are the most
important instead of all the different
things that you can do
says if you focus on doing three to five
things every day towards your goals he
says in one year you'll be in a totally
different destination three years
five ten years your life won't be the
same
and I was tired of living a mediocre to
less than mediocre life and so I said
listen you seem to have a good plan and
a good path you're making millions of
dollars you're giving a lot of money to
charity you're happy you're healthy
you've got a great family I want that he
said if you want that follow the
blueprint don't try to figure it out
just follow the blueprint and that was
another lesson that he shared with me is
that you don't have to reinvent the
wheel yes like if you want to fly right
now you don't have to figure out how to
fly you know there's already a blueprint
for how to generate or create an
airplane yeah so if you want to be
healthy there's already a blueprint if
you want to make more money there's
already a blueprint if you want to buy
real estate or the stock market or start
a business and grow a business there's
people before us
that have already got the blueprint and
all you have to do is paint paint the
numbers inside the box and then you can
use your creativity so I just became a
very good follower for a long time of
things that worked and when you follow
things that work it's like having the
combination to a safe
if someone gives you the combination to
a safe and they tell you turn this way a
little bit turn this way a little bit
turn this way a little bit turn this way
a little bit then open it
you can have access to it but most
people don't look for the combination
and then even when they get the
combination they try it in the wrong
order I was born in Tel Aviv Israel and
moved to Montreal because my parents
were tired of raising their kids in A
Worn torn part of the world which was
you know in Israel and the Palestinian
areas and I'm sure everybody felt that
same way that whole region my parents
moved to Montreal from Israel and at the
time I really had a hard time learning
the French in the English language and I
developed some I guess self-esteem
issues that I wasn't smart enough or as
good as the other kids because I
couldn't communicate when I was really
young and then I got into a lot of
trouble as a as a young teen from the
age of 12 to 17. I got into a lot of
trouble with the law mostly because
I had low self-esteem if you can believe
that
um I did at the time are you interested
in achieving that vision for your life
are you interested in achieving those
goals or are you committed
are you interested or are you committed
and I didn't know what the difference
really was at the time and so I asked Mr
Brown what's the difference and he said
to me says if you're interested you'll
do what's convenient if you're
interested you'll use the fact that you
didn't like school and you didn't do
well in school to control your thinking
and your self-esteem you said if you're
interested you'll come up with stories
and excuses why you can't achieve those
goals and dreams that you shared with me
you'll come up with stories and excuses
as to why you don't want to do the work
necessary to grow and to learn what you
need to learn
he says however
if you are committed he says you will do
whatever it takes you will upgrade your
knowledge you'll upgrade your skills you
will become who you need to become and
you'll learn from whoever you need to
learn to be able to achieve those goals
and dreams so lesson number one
is no matter what goal or Vision you
have
ask yourself that question okay are you
interested in achieving that goal and
dream
or are you really really really
committed and willing to do whatever it
takes when I was 19 years old okay when
I had a mentor a man who was in his 50s
very very successful he agreed to to
Mentor me and to teach me what he knew
and so he sent me home with some paper
and on the paper it said
what do you want to achieve in your
health
what do you want to achieve in your
relationships what do you want to
achieve financially what do you want to
achieve charity what do you want to
achieve as far as experiences when do
you want to retire by how much money do
you want to make well how he asked me
about 10 pages of questions
and at 19
I I had no idea how much do I want to
make I want to make enough to pay my
bills I want to make enough to you know
just eat well and then have some fun I
want to go drinking with my friends I
want to go party and travel a little bit
and pay for my apartment and a nice car
and things like that but he had me think
you know one year
five years 25 years when I was 19 and he
made me write down
the answers to these questions even
though they weren't I had no idea how to
achieve them he made me write it down it
took me a whole weekend
and I went back and he looked at my
papers and so he looked at health and
wealth and relationships and career and
business and he goes good way to do the
exercise I'm very proud of you he says
now I want you to increase that amount
and so I said that you know by the time
I was 45 I was 19. I said by the time I
was 45
I was going to be a millionaire
nobody in my family
was a millionaire not my aunts not my
uncles not my cousins nobody in the area
that we lived in and I wrote that down
and he said no that's not enough he says
you can do better than that and I'm like
I'm swallowing I'm scared I'm afraid I'm
how am I going to become more than that
how can I have all of this he says don't
worry about the how right now
you worry only and not even worry but
you write down what you want
[Music]
and so I went back home
and started to write again a game and
and took another you know half a day to
to redo my goals
and he said to me great now in order for
you to achieve those goals what do you
have to believe
well I said well I have to believe that
I can I have to believe that I deserve
it and even though I didn't believe that
I deserved it he said what would you
think you had to believe I have to
believe that it could be done I have to
believe that I could learn the skills I
would have to believe so he made me
write out what I would have to believe
good question and then he said great
what do you think you would have to do
every day wow amazing question
um well I guess I would have to come to
work every day and I'd have to really
get good at what I'm doing and I'd have
to learn more that I'm learning right
now because I hated to learn back then
and I'd have to you know gain more
skills which I didn't have any the only
thing I was good at was I had an easy
time talking to people like I am with
you now and he said great well let's
make a list of all of these things and
let's come up with a plan
to do this is that so every day let's
look at some beliefs
and so every day he would have me look
at my goals and I would sit in my chair
and I'd have my goals you know that he
had me right and I would take my fingers
which he told me to touch my goals so
that I would send a message to my brain
as I was reading it and seeing it to
reinforce the goals that I wrote
then I would read
the beliefs
that I needed to have
I have all the intelligence I need to
achieve these goals
I can now acquire all the skills to
achieve these goals and I read about 20
or 30 different beliefs every day
and for the first month or two months
while I was reading all of this in my
head
this one word kept coming up you know
what the word was
because as I would read it my brain
would say
that's not true and he told me that my
brain would try to talk to me and tell
me it's not true and he said if you keep
doing it over and over and over again
your brain's going to get tired of
telling you it's not true and especially
if after you do this you take some
actions
to upgrade your knowledge upgrade your
skills you'll develop more confidence
and more certainty
so he taught me how to use the telephone
to make telephone calls to people
to see if they were interested in buying
a real estate property or selling their
home I was in real estate at 19.
and you know for the first month it was
hard second month it was hard the third
month it was hard but as I got better
and more comfortable at being on the
telephone talking to people that I
didn't know that I thought didn't want
to hear from me or talk to me
I found one person then two people then
three people then five people who said
yes
because as I became more comfortable as
I became more skilled as I gained more
knowledge
people received me differently
and in my first year I made thirty
thousand dollars I was 19.
which was five thousand dollars more
than my father made as a taxi driver wow
then he started to upgrade my skills a
little bit more and he started to teach
me some very specific
things to do in real estate and in my
second year at 20 I made a hundred and
fifty one thousand dollars wow five
times more income because every day for
one hour
one hour a day I practiced
my beliefs I practiced seeing my vision
I rehearsed it I got on the phone I
upgraded my knowledge I upgraded my
skills I love your story thank you and
and so he kept he kept directing me a
little bit at a time to become more
tomorrow than I am today
and he said to me something that changed
my life
it says if you invest one hour a day
on your personal growth and changing who
you believe you are
that is the equivalent of nine
40 hour weeks
of effort
one hour day for a year is nine 40 hour
weeks if you and I said today we're
going to learn break dancing we're going
to learn knitting and we're going to
spend nine weeks 40 hours a week
we would get good at what painting we
would get good at at knitting we would
get good at darts we would get good at
playing a musical instrument if we were
committed to one hour a day
so I've practiced one hour a day for 32
years
and that one hour a day
has changed my life we all have these
patterns
that are subconscious that are driving
our behaviors more than our conscious
efforts
and so when we're dealing with the
gorilla in the brain and again it's a
metaphorical way to look at it you have
to understand that the gorilla is going
to get whatever the gorilla is wired to
get the gorilla does not care about what
you consciously want
the gorilla
um really focuses on the patterns that
are going to keep it safe and here's
what safe means safe just means comfort
zone let's say you're miserable let's
say you're broke let's say you're
overweight let's say you're in a
relationship that you you don't like
let's say you're a job you don't love
that is safe to the gorilla why because
it knows the pain it's already dealing
with it knows the discomfort it knows
the price it's paying already versus
getting out of that comfort zone leaving
the job that you're not happy with
leaving a relationship that you're not
in love with
um trying to earn more income getting
out of debt you can be in debt and
comfortable you could be in a
relationship you hate and comfortable
you could be at a job that you don't
love and comfortable and the gorilla is
gonna keep you in your comfort zone
let's say you have a fear of
public speaking is it really a fear of
public speaking that you have or is it a
fear of getting up on stage and being
embarrassed ashamed ridiculed or judged
let me take you to another type of fear
being buried alive can you imagine for
just a moment if there was an earthquake
or there was a natural disaster and
somehow you were buried alive
wouldn't that trigger this crazy amount
of fear of dying while you were buried
alive now why am I taking you there I'm
taking you there because fear is a
subconscious trigger whenever we feel
threatened and the threat could be a
threat for our very lives and when that
happens we move into one of four
modalities and modality number one is we
try to fight this feeling number two is
we freeze because we're in such shock
number three we may faint because of the
neurochemistry that the fear causes or
we might run away if we can run away now
these neurological reactions are our
brain's way of keeping us safe which is
the highest need and desire of the brain
safety of above all else so when we are
looking to achieve a goal that we want
to achieve and it doesn't matter if it's
you know to start a business or grow
your business or leave a relationship
that you're not happy in or a job that
you're miserable in
whenever we think about the actual
behavior that is required to achieve
that goal
once we get motivated in doing that
that's part one of how our brain works
but right after that our brain has to
analyze if there's any real or imagined
danger associated with taking that
action step so if you are going to leave
a relationship that you're not happy in
your brain is going to activate the
memory circuits and discover what's in
there that may have caused you pain and
suffering in the past and when that
happens whether it's a relationship you
want to leave a job that you want to
leave a goal you want to achieve your
brain is always analyzing is there any
danger here and when there is real or
imagined Danger
the amygdala part of the brain the
emotional response Center in the brain
is going to fire off an amazing amount
of neurochemicals like cortisol
epinephrine or norepinephrine and it's
that Rush of those neurochemicals that
causes this emotion energy in motion we
label as fear now once you have that
Rush of neurochemicals in your
bloodstream that actually gives you an
enormous amount of energy
but what most people never have learned
how to do is how to take that energy and
channel it to action versus to fighting
it freezing or running away when you
recognize a fear I want you to do this
it's called inner size number one it's
called take six calm the circuits when
fear neurochemicals are released in your
brain you've activated the fear or
stress response Center in the brain when
you just observe
the emotion called fear through being
quiet and breathing six times in through
your nose and out through your mouth
like this you take a deep breath in for
five seconds
[Music]
you blow out like you're blowing out
through a straw and if you do this five
seconds in five seconds out five seconds
in five seconds out with six to ten
breaths
you're going to deactivate the fear
response Center and that actually is
going to reactivate your thinking Center
in your brain so that you can move on to
Inner size number two inner size number
one is take six calm the circuits inner
size number two is called Aya a i a and
that stands for awareness intention
action so here's how you do this after
you do the first inner size then you
move to Inner size number two and then
you ask yourself in a calm relaxed state
what am I thinking right now what am I
feeling right now am I calm or am I
tense am I breathing deeply or shallow
is my heartbeat fast or slow and in this
state of calm awareness
as you deactivate the brain's fear or
stress response you can observe
what you are feeling and what you are
thinking and what you were doing and
then
you can ask yourself the next question
that is the I what is my intention right
now is my intention to move forward or
is my intention to stay in this fearful
State and chances are you gonna say well
I really want to move forward
and then you ask self what is one action
step that I can take
to move forward towards my goal and
dream so this is how it works after you
do the inner size number one to calm the
circuits and to deactivate the reactive
state that fear causes and then you move
into the second inner size called Aya to
move into the responsive state
awareness intention action now puts you
in control of being aware of the fear
being aware okay of what you've been
thinking and then being at choice of
what you want to do so when you combine
these two inner sizes you are now
reconfiguring the neural network in your
brain around the goal that you want to
achieve and instead of allowing the real
or imagined danger to control you and to
stop you dead on your tracks you take
one action step in a calm State and that
rewires your brain so that the same
reaction doesn't hold you back anymore
and that you are now able to use fear as
your fuel for success is your financial
Governor holding you back from doubling
or tripling your income in the next six
to 12 months now you may be asking John
what in the world is a financial
governor and I'll explain it this way
many years ago when the car companies
were Building engines that were faster
and stronger and more resilient cars
could go 200 250 miles an hour some
maybe even to 300 miles an hour but
because of laws in Europe and the in the
United States these Governors were put
on the engine so that the car even
though it can go faster and perform even
better it was limited to about 155 miles
per hour so here we are we have these
cars that can go extremely fast but for
obvious reasons to conserve on gas to be
able to have more safety on the roads
and to keep us generally all driving
around the same speed limit we created
these Governors to put on engines in
order to limit the speed at which the
car can go at well what does that have
to do with you earning more money you
accumulating more wealth and the answer
is everything
if you understand that you have a
conscious brain that wants to set goals
but you have a subconscious mind that is
going to limit your thoughts emotions
feelings and behaviors to what you are
governed by which is your subconscious
mind
then here's one of the things that we
have discovered
people who make thirty thousand dollars
a year or 50 or 100 or 500 000 a year or
a million dollars a year or more their
financial Governor is set at a totally
different setting than somebody who's
earning less so why does this make a
difference well it makes a difference
because there's a part of your brain
that chooses the goal that you want to
achieve and there's another part of your
brain that's responsible for everything
else your thoughts emotions feelings and
behaviors and so if you don't have
coherence between these two parts of
your brain if you don't know how to
remove the governor and reset it chances
are you're going to have goals and
dreams Financial ones and even lifestyle
ones that you're not going to achieve
not because you're not capable of doing
it it's just because you are wired set
conditioned programmed whatever you want
to call it to earn the income you're
earning right now and maybe a little bit
more each day each week each month
versus doubling or tripler quintupling
your income now let me give you a
different visual for this that'll
hopefully cement what I mean let's say
you're in a room that has a thermostat
in there and the thermostat is set to a
nice and comfortable 70 degrees and you
feel nice at that temperature what
happens if you open up a window and
let's say it's winter and cold air comes
in well what happens is the mechanism in
the thermostat that picks up what the
temperature is in the room picks up a
deviation that cold air is come in the
room and what does it do it sends a
signal through the electoral system for
the heater to go on so that the room
gets back to 70 degrees that's called a
cybernetic mechanism a control and
respond mechanism that occurs in
machines that we create them in or in
animals like us so whether it's hot air
coming into a room or cold air coming
into a room any deviation from the set
program activates the air conditioning
or the heat until the program and the
room are one and the same that is a
cybernetic mechanism as I mentioned and
here's what happens in US humans if
you're used to earning thirty thousand
or fifty thousand seventy five a hundred
or two hundred or more or you are used
to a certain lifestyle any deviation up
or down from that setting that comfort
zone that programming
kicks in your nervous system so that you
either turn up the Jets and earn more
based on what you're used to or if you
do really well for a week a month a
quarter you actually back off and
sabotage your success until you meet the
setting that you have in your mind that
is how a governor Works in a car that's
how a governor works in your brain so if
you want to double or triple your income
in the next six months 12 months two
years
doesn't it make sense that you should
reset your financial Governor the
expectation point the programming the
conditioning
well of course it does what I've seen in
my years of training whether it's sales
people or entrepreneurs or individuals
to make more money is the ones that
think that they could do it just by
gaining more knowledge
missed the point because as a part of
our brain that gains more knowledge but
doesn't change Behavior what you have to
do is reprogram your financial set point
your conditioning the expectation point
and when you do that and you create this
coherence between your goal and your
dream and your subconscious programming
that is when your behavior starts to
change that is when fears dissipate that
is when you stop procrastinating that is
when you take inspired action and you
don't sabotage the success that you are
achieving
so in order to achieve your goals and
dreams you have to reset your Governor
reset your financial thermostat the
fascination that I have is around living
in a world
right now where we have access to all
the how to how do I make more money how
do I grow my business how to have a
great relationship how do I you know
find the love of my life how do I put a
rocket ship on Mars and a lot of people
are confusing having information and how
to with actually doing it and I've been
fascinated just in understanding how do
I help people
unleash more of their potential that
already exists and a lot of people may
have heard you know they say that we
only use five to ten percent of our
brain that's not true we use a hundred
percent of our brain's capacity and
neural networks every moment of every
day but the potential to use more
is there and so our researchers at
neurogym really are uncovering how to
take the best information from the world
of neuropsychology neuroscience and give
it to Everyday People so they can say
okay how do I overcome my fear of not
being good enough my fear of not being
smart of my fear of being embarrassed or
ridiculed or ashamed or fear of
failure or fear of success these are all
psychological issues that everybody
feels but very few people understand
when I feel that what do I do about it
so that I can unlock more of my
potential so I can actually take more
action first on the things I already
know that I could be and should be doing
but I'm not and next on the behaviors
that I could be taking to achieve My
Success easier and faster and that's
really my my passion is helping people
unlock that amazing potential within
them I was taught the Law of Attraction
you know I was 23 24 years old
um also at a real estate conference
they're talking about this Law of
Attraction thing that there's this
energy everything's made up of energy I
am energy you are energy and my thoughts
you know create this resonance between
what I attract and what I don't I'm like
oh God I like that you know I want to
attract more of the good stuff right
um and so I I bought in like I bought
into stuff that just made sense to me
but then I was a voracious student I
want to understand how
like explain to me how it works like if
somebody tells me visualize I go why
like how does it work like if you ask me
to visualize like why does it work like
why should I invest my time on that
versus something else if you're asking
me to use affirmations like how
specifically why how does it work if
you're asking me to emotionalize well
what's happening in me the time I need
to create these false senses of feelings
I want to know why it works the law of
Goya is is simply get off your ass so if
you if you if you if you think and you
believe and you emotionalize you
visualize and you create your plan for
how am I actually going to achieve this
so what do I need to do when am I going
to do it how specifically how am I gonna
tweak it measure it and iterate it so
that I'm consistently making progress I
learned the value of progress versus
perfection
none of my mentors ever had me focus on
Perfection they had me focus on progress
to just keep getting better little
incremental gains every day every week
every month every quarter and even when
you move backwards a couple of steps
What's the progress that you made and
what you learned
so I was taught that failure is an
opportunity to learn and I was also
taught to disassociate me being a
failure from failing when you start
talking about my brain it's an organ
it's like your heart is an organ you can
speed up your heart you can slow down
your heart you can you know speed up the
brain waves in your brain you can slow
them down you can tune in you can tune
out yeah we haven't been given the
user's manual for the most powerful
we're aware of that's right and so the
great news you know I know you being an
athlete in a successful businessman you
have discipline you cannot
I think you can't achieve yourself
achieve results without some kind of
discipline and so we know that there's
some fundamental truths to achieving
success and every successful person will
tell you you know and Jim Rohn is I know
you you love Jim Royce so you either pay
the price of discipline or you pay the
price of regret discipline weighs ounces
regret weighs tons but the thing is can
you teach discipline the answer is yes
how you have to have a willing
participant and if the participants
reason why
is big enough if they know I want to
achieve X and the reason why the motive
for their action motivation the motive
for their action
is a reason Beyond just themselves
chances are they will do more
yeah to achieve that success than if it
was just left up to their own but there
are some people that are born you know
with Incredible Drive they just have
this insatiable drive and they'll just
I'll do whatever it takes
for the things that I want and there's
other people that want things but they
just don't have this insatiable Drive
and this is where you know I as much as
I hated school I love to use schools and
analogy yeah in The Game of Life whether
it's health wealth relationships career
business spirituality fun experiences
you have to decide what level the game
do I want to play at is it the great
school level the kindergarten level the
high school level the university level
the pro level because each one of those
levels requires a totally different
mindset and totally different skill set
they're building blocks on each other
but if you are extremely talented but
you're not prepared to practice and
rehearse and drill and fall and fail
forward to the next attempt you will
never make it as a pro you will never
make as a pro business person you'll
never make it as a pro husband or wife
or athlete or musician you just never
will so just get used to that if you're
not prepared to pay the price
if you are prepared to pay the price and
you have the aptitude the talent now
we're talking about there's some real
potential here and what we don't know is
you know what's in your heart like what
is the fire that stirs you that that you
wake up saying I will do this even when
I don't feel like it I will do whatever
it takes to overcome my Temptation for
mediocracy my Temptation for excuses my
Temptation for
um reasons and circumstances to hold me
back I won't allow those to be in my way
and if you have that within you you'll
achieve whatever you choose right and so
the question you asked before is how do
you develop that start small yeah start
small
so if you don't have discipline show to
your show yourself that you can give
yourself one command and one follow
through so you know what
um right now I'm going to get up I'm
going to do two push-ups right now not
not like later now can you give yourself
a simple command one sit-up right now
I'm gonna go get a glass of water you
start with something ridiculous I
learned many years ago reduce it to the
ridiculous so for reducer to the
Ridiculousness I start I said can you do
that great will you
because that's the difference right
there is that's the razor's Edge the
people who can will you will you yeah
great when now now yeah right so if you
develop that skill and specifically from
a brain plasticity a neuroplasticity
perspective as soon as you do that you
give yourself a command
and you take the action you have just
created a neural pattern that you can
give yourself a command and take action
now that maybe just be one time well
what if you did that every hour by
putting a little bell on your computer
and every hour like if you're if my
computer was open I'd have um every hour
it would say it's 12 o'clock it's one
o'clock and I take 60 Seconds
just to be in control of my mind 66 I
don't care what you're doing stop takes
six breaths just get it just gets
centered am I on track am I off track am
I doing something I shouldn't be doing
versus a high impact activity that I
need to be doing every hour I've trained
myself to just reset
I didn't always do that so I just
started with
One A Day right then two sure then three
then it was working so well I said great
let's do this every hour the first thing
that you have to ask is what are your
highest values
so for me for example my number one
highest value is God my number two value
is my health my number three value is my
family my number four value is
contribution to the lives of others my
number fifth value is fun so every day
when I wake up I think about what am I
doing today to connect with God for me
just for me it doesn't have to be you
know it's not religious it's just for me
then what do I need to do every day to
make sure that I'm healthy what I need
to do every day to make sure that my
family and my dear close friends who are
part of my family that I have the
relationship that's rich
then contribution how do I use my my
passion my gifts my my stories my things
I've not done well things I have done
how do I share that with the world
and in doing that I feel good and then I
have to have fun
and so if I do those five things every
day
then at the end of every day I've had a
great day
and if you have a lot of great days then
you end up with a really great life and
that doesn't mean that you don't have
ups and downs and things that don't work
and trouble that happens and things that
come up but if you keep your focus on
what's important
then the rest of the stuff is really
inconsequential
and there isn't a hundred different
things you have to do
there's two or three things in each one
of the areas that's important to you
when you do those every day
you're so far ahead of the curve I want
to separate like behaviors and emotions
so usually when people say they have
they're having a bad day sure certain
things may have gone wrong or something
that they tried to do you know didn't
work out
all information experience is a
processed at the non-conscious brain
first and then it gives rise to
something we call a Feeling
so emotions are processed
non-consciously the electrical and
chemical reaction to that is called a
feeling so when I'm not feeling
the way that I want to feel I don't
focus on the feeling I focus on the
cause the neuroelectrical charge that's
occurred in my brain and in most cases
it's something that you're doing to
interpret an event that's causing the
neuroelectrical signal causing the
feeling so in meditation for example why
do you meditate
well obviously it's great for a whole
host of of health reasons whether it's
um it's uh less stress less you know
lower blood pressure uh less cortisol
release Etc but the one thing meditation
does more than anything else is it gives
you the ability to have a pause of
awareness
so that you sense
what's happening at the non-conscious
level right and what's happening outside
of you so so when somebody behaves a
certain way
it's processed at the non-conscious
level gives rise to your conscious mind
for you to respond
and so when something happens I like to
be able to check in
so that I don't react and I have the
ability to respond
enough through mindfulness being aware
just being aware of exactly what's going
on then you have fewer and fewer of
those times so you know something
happened last week I was in a hotel room
and I spilled some water on a shirt that
I needed for a wedding that we were
going to and my wife
she's going off deeper now it's just
calm yeah and she goes aren't you
worried about this will it help right
but no let's just figure out what to do
the accident already happened did you
know that some of the most recent
studies on setting goals and writing
them out or typing them out on your
computer will actually increase your
chances of achieving those goals by up
to 42 percent why well as soon as you
put the energy to writing out your goals
and getting Clarity you're giving your
brain the instruction that this is
what's important to you this is what you
want to achieve so don't be like all the
other people where they have goals and
dreams and they hope and pray for it to
work be the type of person who sets
hurdles or his goals in writing and then
focus on that every day and you'll
achieve more of your goals beautiful
thing about the time that we're living
in now
is we can share knowledge and
experiences and anybody with a you know
a phone an iPad or a smartphone or an
Android or a computer anywhere in the
world in the Kalahari Desert in
Antarctica can get access and get
inspired the best ideas in the world
yeah to get the best ideas in the world
but to see that you're no different none
of us are different the illusion
is that we're different because we're
comparing Who We Are
compared to the person that we're
listening to or learning from or we're
seeing the Gap and the Gap is what
causes to be uncomfortable but if we
remember we're all spiritual we're all
made from the exact same thing you know
if you think about the human body it's
made of hydrogen oxygen nitrogen carbon
helium there's there's elements but we
came from the furnaces of stars
you can't have carbon okay in the human
body that didn't come from the inside of
a star
helium and hydrogen is what the big bang
was initially made up of and then as all
the gases coalesced and created stars
and then galaxies
we became our flesh and blood and
everything that we became the organism
has come from the universal intelligence
that's why we're all connected and
that's why we all have the same
abilities different skills
different knowledge but the same
abilities to become all of the ideas
goals and dreams that we have
and so we just have to say that is what
I want to trade my life for and even
though I don't know how even though I
may not feel totally comfortable or
confident or I'm lacking certainty
let's get let's get on the path
and then we can change the world
together let's say you know you and I
are buddies we want to start a business
or we have a business come on let's
crush it all right let's do this thing
let's triple our income this year let's
make 30 percent more net revenues let's
travel the world let's live this
lifestyle that's amazing and we get
excited right so we go oh yeah oh my God
that's great let's do this high fives
all around dopa means release we feel
great we shared with our friends we
release oxytocin so we bonded oh my God
I love you and you love me and we feel
great we're going to conquer the world
and that happens all the time but let's
say that underneath the hood
there's a fear of I'm not smart enough
or I'm not good enough or what if I fail
and I embarrass myself what if I succeed
and I can't maintain it what if I'm
ridiculed because I try so hard and my
friends will laugh at me
there are 50 5-0 different types of
fears that are almost in everybody's
memory bank that gets brought up to the
surface and when the fear circuit lights
up which is fam automatically within
either moments hours or days when you
start realizing holy what is it going to
really take to double or triple my
income into and to take the time off
that I want as soon as that happens
when the fierce circuit lights up then
the system the the neuroelectrical
chemical system floods with epinephrine
cortisol and norepinephrine what is that
those are just three of the hundred
chemicals in the brain
that are part of the stress response
system whenever you and I and everybody
watching or listening
thinks about or feels that there's
potential danger potential pain whether
it's emotional pain like being
embarrassed or ashamed or financial pain
like not being able to have enough money
to pay for my food or for my burger for
my cocktails or for my rent or my car or
my airline ticket if there is real or
imagined
possibility of discomfort pain
the break on motivation slams shut
and we start to procrastinate
so we have this incredible system that
can give us this motivation the motive
for Action to go forward but we have to
temper it with our ability to recognize
the trigger and the sensation in our
body called a Feeling
that the non-conscious processing part
of the brain that gives us this emotion
called fear all fear is processed at the
non-conscious level of your awareness
and then gives rise into the frontal
lobes
of the feeling that your body has the
average person that has not been trained
feels fear and puts the break on and
goes and Retreats into what they're
comfortable doing
the successful person either they may be
genetically wired to understand feeling
fear and doing it anyway turning Their
Fear into fuel but that's not the
majority of people that's why 90 plus
percent of people fail and stay in that
position but you can take that fuel that
hypersensitive Rocket Fuel I call it and
utilize it to actually motivate you
faster further than you ever got before
yeah fascinating systems if you don't
know how to use them too bad it's like
not knowing that a gun has got bullets
in it and you pull the tree the holy
just blew my brains out not that you'd
be able to you know say that you'd be
like game over but ignorance is not your
friend when it comes to neurochemistry
if you want another amazing John Ashraf
video check it out right there next to
me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there